[Music]
morning everybody tories trance
lib dems are very happy this uh this
morning they've won an unexpected
by-election victory
from the conservatives sarah green
overturned a majority of more than
16 000 in cheshire and amisham which is
in buckinghamshire
a seat which has been held by the tories
since 1974.
this is the final result for you you can
see sarah green is now the mp for
cheshire and amisham
with the majority as just over eight
thousand and the share shows that huge
win by the lib dems with
56.7 of the vote
compared to 35.5 percent for the second
place tories
a reversal from the 2019 general
election
the lib dem vote share was up more than
30 points conservatives greens and labor
were all down
here's our political correspondent rob
powell
liberal democrats 21
517 votes a huge win in the conservative
home counties
overturning a chunky and sustained tory
majority
and winning comfortably by 8 000 votes
this is a stunning victory for the lib
dems
in the heart of true blue suburbia a
stone's throw from the prime minister's
constituency
we will continue the work of holding
this government to account
for letting kovid rip through the care
homes we will speak
speak up for the three million people
excluded from financial support
throughout the pandemic and we will
challenge boris johnson
to be far more ambitious in tackling
climate change
as counting began there have been rumors
of a tight race
but even the lib dems will be surprised
by the size of their win in this
by-election
called after the death of former mp dame
cheryl gillum the constituency has been
conservative since its creation in 1974
with torres representing the area for
far longer than that
the losing candidate left licking his
wounds it's
absolutely extraordinary result which
must take into account the fact that the
liberal democrat party didn't just throw
the kitchen sink
at this constituency i think it was the
microwave the table the oven the
dishwasher the dog the cat and anything
else
that was lying around as well in
affluent buckinghamshire on the fringes
of london
cheshire and amisham is for many the
definition of a leafy tory stronghold
but a mix of local and national concerns
have formed a potent cocktail for the
lib dems here
the area voted comfortably to remain in
the eu while the high-speed 2 rail link
is a big concern
alongside proposed changes to the
planning rules the lib dem leader says
this shows amid a focus on levelling up
in the north
the tories are ignoring the south
whether this is a genuine realignment or
just a midterm protest vote
the win here is one of the most
surprising by-election results in recent
history
and will worry those in tory ranks
already concerned that in a bid to win
new supporters in the north
the government is taking for granted
their traditional strongholds in the
south
rob powell sky news
[Applause]
kit malthus for the government joining
us now good morning to you mr malt house
thanks for taking the time what on earth
has happened
in amisham well it's obviously very
disappointing can't pretend anything
otherwise
really sad for our fantastic candidate
peter fleet i was there myself
just a couple of days ago knocking on
doors for him
we'll obviously have to have a fairly
significant post-match analysis and
understand what has actually
gone on um and i suppose you know
traditionally it's always tough for
governments whatever eleven years in
uh midterm to winner by election but you
know there are lessons there for
everybody and no doubt they'll become
clear in the days to come
are you ignoring the home countries as
is the allegation in favor of creating a
new base up north
well as a home county's member of
parliament myself i don't think we are
no
um and it's worth pointing out that only
uh just a month ago
uh we had fantastic results across the
home counties in local election results
certainly in my own
home borough of basingstoke and dean we
took the the borough from no overall
control with a fairly resounding victory
had a clean sweep across the board in
the county so you know the there's some
complex things going on there which i
think we'll need to understand and no
doubt
uh people at party headquarters will be
focusing on the result and trying to
understand how we can win
uh cheshire and amisham back at the next
opportunity 30-point swing is
embarrassing though isn't it well look
it's tough and disappointing as i say
uh we would have hoped for a better
results can't pretend anything otherwise
but
you know the we've seen this by-election
phenomenon in the past
um our job now is to win back the trust
of the people in that
lovely part of buckinghamshire and uh
make sure at the next opportunity we uh
resoundingly win it back
what is it about politicians when they
always say it's a phenomenon when a
by-election doesn't go their way
and yet it's at the course of politics
in the united kingdom when it goes your
way
uh well no i don't think that is the
case i mean everybody looked at the the
last by-election and thought that was a
fairly extraordinary thing
uh midterm traditionally midterm it's
been difficult for governments
to win by elections people feel the need
to make a protest this is an unusual one
i said it's disappointing
um and we'll need to understand what was
going on there as your report said your
package said obviously
uh people very concerned about hs2 bit
odd because of course the liberal
democrats big supporters of hs2 so
what's that telling us we need to
understand those things in the days to
come
and no doubt that analysis will will be
done i mean we
control uh local government pretty much
in the area pretty resoundingly i think
26 out of 27
councils are conservative in that area
um and so you know there are obviously
lessons to be learned and that's what
we'll try and do
uh you are policing and crime minister
which is uh of course why we'd like to
speak to you more seriously
this morning if i can put it that way um
the rape review
that is appalling reading isn't it and
charities and victims groups are saying
um that uh what you're suggesting or
to try and fix it lacks urgency and is
underfunded why do you think that's not
the case
well it's obviously a shocker i mean as
we've we've said in the report
and on the median elsewhere you know
it's it's a source of deep regret and
shame
the numbers have dropped so
significantly um over the last few years
the reasons for that
are are complicated and what we've tried
to do in the report is tease them out
um but then put in place a structure a
set of proposals
which we believe uh stand the best
chance of driving significant change as
quickly as possible
now one of the challenges in doing so is
obviously we're dealing with very large
operational
uh situations you have big police forces
the crown prosecution service the courts
all of whom are operationally
independent we have to respect their
decision-making
on charge prosecution how they conduct
themselves in
in court but at the same time apply
you know policy and pressure to try and
get significant change in this
area and while i understand you know
groups are naturally impatient and we're
very sorry
uh for what's happened over the last few
years they're naturally patient for
change
you know my experience tells me after
whatever 20 years in public policy
delivery that actually building from a
strong base
starting with a focused set of proposals
is most likely to get us changed
in the short term where do you stand on
victims having to hand in their phones
when they make an allegation um
when there's it needs to be searched
after an attack their phone to see
what's on it uh campaigners are calling
that a digital strip
search yeah so one of the challenges
of modern crime fighting has been the
advent of the the smartphone
and the vital role it plays in
investigations
um and that's not just rape and sexual
assault investigations where it's very
important but you know
no murder in this country is solved
without mobile phone
uh data now being interrogated and our
technology to do that
um is not fast enough very often victims
sadly
are asked to surrender their phones for
too long
it's too intrusive it has an impact on
them and their willingness to continue
uh with the prosecution and so what
we're going to try and do
is get to a situation where no victim
goes without their phone
for more than 24 hours and if they are
we can offer them a replacement phone so
that they can communicate and do what
they
uh need to do and also that the
interrogation of the data on that phone
is very restricted through new
guidelines uh
such that the evidence that's followed
is only that which is pertinent to the
case
um and what we hope is that that
naturally intrusive
uh inquiry can be less burdensome and
therefore victims are more likely to
stick with the case
okay um you're working from home i think
this morning yep
you are um i am yeah yeah talk to me
about
uh working from home come the 19th of
july or whatever date that is how would
you feel
uh with if your staff your civil
servants said that they wanted to
continue to
work from home at infinitum
well obviously this is a situation for
employers and employees
uh to discuss and negotiate themselves i
mean i know there's been some
uh media about this over the last two or
three days and we don't have any
intention to make
um it compulsory to return to the office
our manifesto at the last election did
uh contain a pledge to consult on you
know more flexible working
to allow people to work from home uh
should they wish to and we'll be doing
that
uh later on this year but you know i
think most situations and as a small
business person myself in the past
uh most of these situations can be
sorted out between employers and
employers
i have to say though from a personal
point of view one of the things i think
we all need to bear in mind is it's very
hard
for young people coming up through an
organization to learn remotely
to interact with their seniors and to
learn from them and get nuanced and have
those casual conversations
which help with their training and their
skill set
very hard remotely um and i'm sure
employers will be taking that into
account
okay so it answered my question you
would be happy if your civil servants
wanted to work from home going forward
or not well it depends
uh so quite a lot of them are very keen
to come in uh
for particular meetings and meet in
person and we're doing that at the
moment when i was a minister at dwp
for example we did have uh remote
offices you know people in
sheffield and nottingham and other areas
and they would dial into meetings
remotely
i think it's horses for courses k and i
think you know in a modern world where
we've got this amazing ability to
communicate with each other i mean this
this stuff was the uh the stuff of star
trek when i was a kid right
um that now we've got these ability uh
to communicate electronically there are
situations where it's appropriate
and there are others where it's not and
that's for employers to work out in the
same way that you do
when you're doing interviews right okay
let me counter through another couple
while i've got you um can you rule out
early
release um of lockdown on the fifth of
july
so look i am this is a decision
obviously for the prime minister and the
the court of ministers and they're
looking at the data as we go
nobody wants to stay in lockdown any
longer than we need to and i know that
they'll be looking carefully at the
numbers
over the days and weeks to come to see
what can be done
okay um just while i've got you can you
see you see we're just talking about
technology can you see me on your screen
at the moment
i can yes okay have a look at this
hancock do you believe that the health
secretary is hopeless
that was a bit awkward wasn't it well
it's an incredibly unfair question
uh if i'm honest with you i mean simon
stephens is a civil servant it's not his
job
to offer good or bad appraisals of
ministers
as he said i think later on the clip
it's a political question and i think
putting him on the spot like that is a
bit unfair if he wants to oh
he could have just easily is it you know
he's a civil servant but he's also
uh politically adept he could have said
he's sensational we couldn't have done
it without him but he didn't
yeah well if he'd said that he would
have been slammed as well for not being
impartial
the british civil service are naturally
impartial and don't want to stray across
the line into mass and political
questions and particularly
where personality is involved so i don't
blame him for trying to
uh to avoid that question i think it was
a bit unfair to put him on the spot
personally
okay we'll have to agree to disagree on
that one let me see whether we agree to
disagree on this one front page of the
times
this morning saying that you're going to
allow two and a half thousand vips into
the country
uh for euro 2020 ua for fifa officials
they're not going to have to quarantine
they're not going to have to have tests
or that's my understanding how can that
be fair
on other people who either do have to
quarantine in hotels or at home
and then have to have these pcr tests at
great expense or perhaps can't even go
on holiday at all
yeah well okay i haven't seen the detail
of that particular proposal one of the
things we are trying to do though is
obviously
accommodate the euros as much as we
possibly can
and while uh much of the i guess the
concern around coronavirus regulations
has been about you know whether one
situation is fair compared to another
situation
what we're generally trying to do is
make difficult decisions
about the path of a virus at the same
time as trying to enable
the ordinary operation of very special
events uh like the euro
and no doubt um you know the health
professionals
and the immigration professionals at the
home office
and then the senior ministers who make
this decision we'll take all of that
into account
as we proceed i mean look it's a great
competition we're very lucky to have it
we're trying to make it happen
as with as much kind of satisfaction all
around as we possibly can
and that will be taken into account in
the decision over the next few days
who are you sporting tonight england or
scotland oh well i'm an englishman so
i'd be supporting england but
you know uh it's great that we've got
home nations in the
in the uh competition uh all so far
doing well but you know i can't pretend
other than to support my uh the english
team i'm afraid
okay i thought i'd build a bowling
underarm for you at the end it's good to
talk to you kit multis thanks very much
indeed for joining us thank you
thanks kay see you soon see you bye-bye
thank you
i like that still to come on the
programme for you this morning the first
minister of wales announces a four-week
pause to the country's road map out of
lockdown
we'll speak to mark drakeford and that's
add a quarter to eight
following that highly critical report
into rapid investigations
we'll talk to jess phillips she's the
shadow minister for domestic violence
that's at five past eight
[Music]
after an investigation revealed the
manchester arena bombing could have been
prevented we'll speak with the father of
the youngest victim
that's at 8 15.
after less than a month in office edwin
putz has resigned
as leader of the dup it follows an
internal revolt against him by mps
and members of the northern ireland
assembly
joining us now is uh from i should say
from stormont i think he is in belfast
there he is this morning david blevins
of course hi david
good morning to you they didn't think
that through did they
well what an extraordinary story when we
were talking yesterday morning k
it was about a breakthrough that we
thought would secure the devolved
government at stormont 24 hours later
the dup have removed their leader after
just three weeks in the job
and power sharing yet again hangs by a
thread
all eyes are on one man today that's
paul gibbon he was edwin puts nominee to
become
first minister of northern ireland and
took up office
yesterday now the leader survived for 21
days
the new first minister might end up
surviving just
one day because it's very difficult to
see how his position right now
remains tenable it was edwin putt's
decision to
nominate paul given despite the majority
of his mps and members of the stormwind
assembly asking him not to
that led to the party officers last
night meeting and to him deciding it was
time to throw in
the towel and the other big question
that now arises is who succeeds edwin
puts
just a few weeks ago there was a
leadership contest he won it by 19 votes
to 17
and the man he defeated sir jeffrey
donaldson who leads the dup at
westminster
is now front runner to become the
party's third leader
in the space of two months okay for now
thank you thanks a lot
looking at some of the other stories
making news this morning
all adults are now eligible to book
their coronavirus vaccination anyone
aged over 18 is now being urged to
arrange
their job polling has opened in iran's
presidential election
ibrahim raci the head of iran's
judiciary and a hard-line ally of the
supreme
leader ayatollah khomeini is the current
favourite to win
after several moderate candidates were
barred from running
police say a greek man has allegedly
confessed to killing his british wife in
athens weeks after he claimed that she
had been killed
by burglars police sources told sky news
after analyzing
smartwatch data a tracker contradicted
charlamboss and agnastopoulos claimed
that he had been
tied up and instead showing him moving
around the house
after the attack
one of football's oldest rivalries
resumes at wembley later on today with
the match
having huge implications for both
england
and scotland's euro 2020 hopes gareth
southgate's england squad will qualify
for the knockout stage with a win
while scotland are seeking to keep their
hopes of progressing alive
thousands of scotland fans have already
arrived in london ahead of tonight's
clash despite pleas
to stay away james matthews reports
just like old times the tartan army
wembley bound and scotland desperately
seeking a result
we are leaving throughout caledonia in
edinburgh this was journey's start
where even a train trip needs a team
talk
[Applause]
the road to wembley rekindles age-old
rivalries
it does get the hairs on the back of
your neck
moving especially once you're in that
stadium
nowadays we allow the english fans to
come to wembley as well and it's not
just full of scottish fans
it's the magic scene scotland playing
against your oldest
uh competitor i'd like it to go well i
think it will i've got my hope set
so yeah i think it'll go well we really
need to get right in there from the word
go
and predict a 2-1 win to scotland
[Music]
scotland fans have traveled to london by
rail
road and air up to twenty thousand are
expected to be in the city
but only three thousand have tickets for
the stadium
london's mayor city cannes had appealed
to scots not to travel without a ticket
or a safe place to watch the game a fit
again kieran tierney
was among the scotland players who
trained before heading south yesterday
without at least a point from tonight's
game he
and they will return north contemplating
an
early exit we hope to start just as
quick as england do
we'll go out there we'll try and get on
the front foot as early as possible try
and get a hold of the ball
we'll try and make the the players will
try and make themselves feel comfortable
on the pitch on the stage
and if we can get off to a quick start
they'll be good for us
after their opening win over croatia
england start tonight as hot favorites
even if their manager is playing it cool
our objective is qualification so that's
that's what we've got to to focus on i
thought
in the past we've done that well i
thought we did that very well on sunday
you know sunday was a big occasion for
everybody it is the great
wembley pilgrimage a place where scots
have enjoyed some of their
finest football moments the tartan army
has long felt a sense of belonging here
for itself and for this fixture for them
footballs coming home from home
james matthews sky news edinburgh
walking through london last night there
were scotland fans absolutely
everywhere the team can certainly count
on their support this evening
you'll remember us following these
chinese elephants here they come a
little earlier on
in the week well we've been following
for a couple of weeks now haven't they
there we are
uh they're on the move again a group of
15 elephants have been traveling around
southern china for more than a year now
covering
some 310 miles from their home
on a wild reserve in yunnan all the way
to khan ming
which is the provincial capital and home
to seven
million people drone footage shows the
elephants helping themselves to crops
uh-oh and flapping their ears to cool
themselves down
later one of the elephant calves can
also be seen opening up a well
for a drink which is very naughty there
he is
um but yeah they're all having a
fantastic time flapping their ears
to keep themselves cool and there he is
trying to
get a drink and a little bit of a dust
bath as well they do that to
keep themselves they take it on and it's
a bit like sunscreen for them
um did you know that elephants can
communicate
from uh more than two miles away a bit
like me and nas
here's nas hello dallas good morning
say i say i'm an elephant i'm joking i'm
joking and we can communicate from more
than two miles away
i'm not going to come up with any um
dumbo comments
get it anyway weather
looking pretty wet
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways good morning
it's still looking very wet for many
parts of england
over the next few days some heavy and
thundery downpours
and some flashes of lightning are likely
for today whereas
for the north and west it's looking fine
the best of the weather across much of
scotland northern ireland the republic
in the north and west of england and
wales for this afternoon in fact
this morning these areas are generally
starting off dry
and bright it is a chilly start though
even a ground frost in some rural spots
of the north
otherwise it's very wet with cloudy
skies and spells of heavy rain across
many parts of the east midlands central
southern and eastern england
particularly heavy downpours at the
moment down towards parts of the
southeast
and continuing that way into this
afternoon the heaviest of the rain with
some thunderstorms likely across the
eastern parts of norfolk suffolk down
towards essex and
kent and there may be some flashes of
lightning across these areas too
so there is a risk of some of those
torrential downpours
leading to some localized flooding but
for the north and west of
england the west of wales island
northern ireland scotland mainly dry and
sunny
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come on the program for you
this morning as the government
apologizes
for failing rape victims we'll be
speaking to the victims commissioner for
england
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
lib dems have won a historic by-election
victory from the conservatives sarah
green overturned a majority of more than
16
000 in cheshire and amisham in
buckinghamshire a seat which has been
held by the tourists since
1974. i asked the police and crime
minister kit malthouse
how things went so terribly wrong for
the tories
it's tough and disappointing as i say uh
we would have hoped for better results
can't pretend anything otherwise but
you know the we've seen this by election
phenomenon in the past
um our job now is to win back the trust
of the people in that
uh lovely part of buckinghamshire and uh
make sure at the next opportunity we uh
resoundingly win it back
leader ed davey with us now proper
kicking what happened
well i think this will send shockwaves
through the british political system
this was uh liberal democrat victory is
one of our best ever
by-election victories and if it was
repeated across the south of england
literally dozens of conservative mps
would lose their seats to
the liberal democrats and you know we
were finding on the doorstep i came here
16 times i talked to hundreds of
people we were finding they've been
taken for granted they feel
that the conservative party isn't
listening to them many of them aren't
very happy with boris johnson
and i think in areas like this it's
really clear that it's the liberal
democrats who can beat the conservatives
and
boy did we do that last night you
certainly did you absolutely transformed
30 points swing
but we both know we've both been in
politics a long time
and that's very rarely replicated in the
general election
well first of all it was a huge swing i
mean people talked about hartlepool
being a big swing this was more than
almost double hartlepool's swing to us
so this is absolutely huge
and i think people will need to take
notice of this
but also it actually builds on a trend
too in the local elections in the south
of england in places like oxfordshire
cambridgeshire
hertfordshire surrey wheelchair liberal
democrats made
quite big gains off for conservatives so
this is part of a trend
and i've been pointing out to people
that everyone's talking about the red
wall in the north
they should think about the blue wall
and it's that blue wall that liberal
democrats breached last night
we can knock it down in the south with
little democrats taking lots of seats
off the conservatives
i think there's been a growing swell
towards us in these sorts of areas
and so to last night while it was uh you
know i have to say it was much better
than i had expected
it was part of that trend where libel
and cats are beating conservatives
across the south
it's it's a yellow brick in a blue wall
at this stage let's
let's uh let's not get ahead of
ourselves uh mr david but what i would
like to ask you is whether you entered
into
a pact with labour in order to transfer
tories last night
no uh we campaigned on liberal democrat
policies we campaigned on
our strong environmental record our
desire to make sure that
uh planning policy for example was a big
issue here is led by the community by
people
who have a voice rather than the
conservatives propositions
which is to take power away from people
and give it to developers
you know liberal democrats believe we
need more affordable homes greener homes
we need more homes for our young people
but the planning reforms being put
forward by the conservatives
would as teresa may said result in the
wrong homes
in the wrong places so you know that
planning reforms uh
then linked to our strong environmental
campaigning i think is what
tilts the balance for many conservative
voters because there are many voters who
net always vote conservative but last
night they wrote a liberal democrat
and i think there's a trend growing
there so there may be one
yellow brick in the wall uh as of last
night there's many more to follow
what's wrong with a lib lab packed ahead
of the next general election
uh the tories of you know if one looks
back i was looking back earlier on
uh this morning about how many times the
conservatives have been in power as
opposed to any other party
they trans all the rest so although
you're having your moment of glory today
what's wrong with having a lib lab pact
in order
to to be a a better opposition to
uh the government
well very different parties little
democrats want a fairer greener more
caring
country but little democrats are mainly
fighting the conservatives so in the
south of england where we're
particularly strong in parts of london
uh actually in parts of some of the
suburbs in places like manchester
a place like hazel grove cheadle it's
the liberal democrats who are competing
against the conservatives and labour are
not very strong there
so really important wouldn't help you
know liberal democrats i believe
are recovering we are showing as a
result of last night
that we are the ones to beat the
conservatives in so many uh
areas and you know our message of
campaigning and talking to people
and we're great campaigners great
community politicians and because we
listen to people
they do feel uh that we respond to their
their concerns in the way that
conservatives increasingly aren't
uh i think many people certainly in
cheshire american but i think across
the south of england feel the
conservatives almost forgotten them take
them for granted
they feel ignored by them and liberal
democrats are filling that vacuum
so ed how concerned are you about a
story uh on the front page of the times
this morning that says two and a half
thousand vips
are going to be allowed to come to the
united kingdom without having to
quarantine from uefa and fifa
to take part or witness watch um
spectate on the euro 2020s how can that
be fair
although i haven't read the story from
what you just said it does not sound
fair at all and you know it's part of
the way this
conservative government operates there's
one rule for their friends
another rule for the rest of us we saw
that with dominic cummings didn't we
during the pandemic who who broke all
the rules
and didn't pay the price and you know so
often with this conservative government
uh if you're friendly with them you get
special favors that is not the way to do
politics
and actually here in cheshire we did see
a number of people
really cross with boris johnson feel
that he and his government aren't just
out of touch but they're just listening
to developers who give them lots of
money they're
listening to the people who who got huge
amounts of money through contracts
during the pandemic
there's a dissatisfaction with boris
johnson which i don't think the polls
have yet picked up but we were picking
up here on the doorsteps in cheshire
and i think that's one of the reasons
why the liberal democrats had such a
good victory here
fantastic win for you by any measures
um what you're going to have is your
celebratory breakfast three shredded
wheat
and i haven't thought about breakfast
i've been talking to uh uh
people in the media um but you know
we're going to have a celebration
obviously because it's such a big win
you know it's not often that you get a
30 swing i mean i i've got a look at the
history books i think it's the biggest
ever
uh liberal democrat by-election victory
which i think speaks uh volumes
i think it says that you know where we
go out and campaign i came here 16 times
to this by-election talk to hundreds of
people
where we talk to people people listen to
us like our message
and our see how different we are from
the conservatives
and i think we're going to keep plugging
away with our message of a fairer
greener more caring country
we're going to be plugging away and
saying look you know if you want the
homes to be affordable to be
green uh and the homes for young people
there's a different approach from the
conservatives
and i think messages like that in areas
like this
will resonate and i think liberal
democrats can win many many more seats
off the conservatives see i was just
looking for a flippant one-liner but you
were a politician right through to the
tape weren't you sure
thanks very much indeed for joining us
this morning thanks a lot
thank you also this morning the home
secretary and justice secretary say they
are ashamed after a government report
found that
thousands of rape victims were being
failed by the criminal justice system
earlier on the program
the crime and policing minister kit mult
has expressed his regret
at the findings well it's obviously a
shocker
i mean as we've we've said in the report
and on the median elsewhere
you know it's it's a source of deep
regret and shame the numbers have
dropped so significantly
um over the last few years the reasons
for that are are complicated
i understand you know groups are
naturally impatient and we're very sorry
for what's happened over the last few
years they're naturally impatient for
change
you know my experience tells me after
whatever 20 years in public policy
delivery that actually building from a
strong base
starting with a focused set of proposals
is most likely to get us changed
in the short term well the victims
commissioner for england and wales dame
vera bed
is joining us now dave ferry thank you
for joining us what's your response to
the report
it's underwhelming i'm afraid i'm
pleased that the ministers have
apologized i think it will cut no ice
with women
and men whose cases have been dropped
because as ministers now apologize for
the criminal justice system has truly
been disregarding complainants until
they prove that in some way they're
worthy
of support they're now told to the
police and the cps are now told to focus
on the defendant and that's it's
absolutely ridiculous that they have to
be told that at this time
that it is good that they are being told
that so it's underwhelming
many opportunities in it are missed i am
pleased that they are
directing the police in the way that
i've described
i'm pleased that they're going to have a
close look at the quality
of what the cps have been doing to make
sure we get more cases but they are the
right
quality cases so the apology is there
in my view to show an intent that they
will make change
we will drive that change as best we can
if we don't get it well where will
people be who've apologized for
something and not put it right
our viewers this morning will not
believe this figure 99.4
of cases of alleged rape go without
charge
how on earth can that be
it it represents a wholesale
failure of rape complainants
there is very clear evidence in
this rape review and the documents
behind it
that what happens when someone complains
of rape is they cease to be a respected
member of the public
and become a suspiciously dodgy probably
part-like person who has to be
scrutinized through and through and
through
before the police and the cps will put
faith in them
and take their case to call that is
appalling
it is rape myths and stereotypes
of an of a of an ancient kind
which should have no truck in
professional decision making
which have fed in particularly over the
last five years
since the crown prosecution service
scrapped something called the merits
based approach to prosecution
why would you drop something that is
merits based
and leave all of the myths and
stereotypes to come in i think what the
police and the cps do is they think will
uh
is there something here that might make
a jury
riddled with prejudices decide against
the complainant
if so we're not going to take a chance
because it's our reputation at stake
taking wrong cases that i think is in
essence what the ministers have
apologized for and have to have
apologized for
even though this has been an insider
inquiry
and it would have had a lot more
strength to it if you've been done
independently
and not by the very people who've caused
the problem in the first place
nonetheless it becomes clear that that
has been
the approach and it has radically to
change
shifting culture has to start
now dave vera what i i specifically put
to uh the policing minister about one of
those uh planks of criticism that you
were uh adhering uh
alluding to there which is that uh when
a victim
complains her phone or his phone is
taken off them
and it is scrutinized um and it's called
an electronic strip
search and inverted commas and the
minister said that is going to continue
um albeit with some safeguards because
that's
hugely important gathering of evidence
why is it not
i don't say that in some cases there
won't be important evidence both for the
prosecution and
arguably for the defense on somebody's
phone
but there is a research document that
underpins this rape review in which the
cps can be seen
saying are quoted saying we want
every bit of download from the phones
every bit of third-party material we can
possibly get
before we even consider a charge in a
rape case that is there on page
47 in the version i have now that
attitude means that even when
for instance it's a stranger rape they
still demand
an excessive amount of phone intrusion
and things like health notes things like
school reports
before they even consider a charge that
has nothing to do
with finding evidence and everything to
do with what i've described
which is really screening the
complainant for credibility
in one of the proposals to change how
policing
is done the features in this rape review
academics referred in one police force
to the rape investigation section
as a complainant credibility section
and if you didn't pass that even if
there was very powerful evidence for
instance in one or two cases
people who've been raped email and and
complain to their complainant if it's
been part to their defendant if it's
been part
of a relationship and there have been
cases where the person
has emailed back and apologize for a
rape
and still if you can't get over that
credibility
barrier for the complainer the police
never get to look
at the behavior of the defendant so
phones we need independent legal advice
i'm afraid to ensure
that only what is relevant to evidence
is taken off phones
and people are not having all of their
documentation
all of their privacy taken away as well
of course as the phone at the very time
when they need it
that is amazed thank you very much
indeed thanks a lot
um you're watching uh the breakfast
program here on sky news
uh professor green actually is coming up
a little bit later on very much looking
forward
for that meantime sport for you here's
jackie jackie good morning
good morning guess what we're going to
be talking about this morning kay yes it
is the oldest
international fixture in football
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
the other word that i always remember
you referring to in team talks was risk
you're doing one nothing with 15 minutes
ago
what's the point in setting your back
forward
your regular midfield and two strikers
what's the point that
the risk is shove people in the box
because the other team react to that
you shove three and four in the box get
the ball in there
it's that's the risk because you can
lose the break away
the counter attack quite easily and we
watch games that way
you were offended by it felt to me like
you were offended by the club being
beaten by liverpool or city at any level
and it made you angry
and the build-up to those games you
could
your face was more a little bit like it
is now was it a dislike of you was it
the rivalry what was it that made you
feel that way because it was just
different in the club it's my respect to
liverpool
when i was a manager simon i went down
to liverpool
straining for a week and i saw the
intensity of their training and
and the consistency they had
so when i came to united and they were
running all the titles they sent me that
point
and it's like one is aberdeen there's
only two clubs you need to be
in scotland to win the written that's
reason celtic
at that time when i came to united
there's only one club to beat
to win a week that's liverpool so that
was my intention
that was up ever then to produce a team
we could beat them
not necessarily beating them every game
but windy's with the weeks
and uh i knew that if you beat liverpool
you're on the right path i only
recognized this properly when i became
captain for that last four or five years
that you used to stand
outside the dressing room door and the
captain couldn't go out past you until
you were there
every single match you make sure you why
did
it's this influence over referees this
looking down the corridor it's they're
looking at the away team what was the
reason you stood outside that door
so that everybody could see it was it
for your own team or was it for the
others down the court
for their own team okay but there was
one occasion
i don't know if you remember this but we
were doing three nothing to
tottenham autonom and i never said the
word in the dress room do you remember
that yeah i sat in the radio
and it was buddy burning hot too and
this is i do remember actually no
next goal is the winner as i said and i
went to the door
and teddy sharing would played with us
of course was their captain
and they came out to the door and what
looked to me and turned and said to
these players
don't let them score early let's go in
the first minute
remember that yeah i thought i thought
that killed him
i'm with teddy having to say that to
them because i looked at them you know
and they worked for me and i just
come on we can win this
it's a funny game
the year was 1996 and england mania was
sweeping the nation
they weren't buying the spice girls
there was another record flying off the
shelves and a whole nation was behind
one man
and his team fast forward 25 years and
at the home of football
i'm about to take on the biggest
challenge of my life
my mission is simple i've got just seven
days to speak to all 22 of terry's boys
get my euro 96 shirt signed and get
committed to getting 100 million people
20
more active by 2025.
and i think whales are playing tomorrow
are they again stationary i think i'm
right in saying that um we're speaking
to the first minister now
um wales delaying the further easing of
its coveted 19 restrictions for four
weeks the country's
seen as spiking cases of the delta
variant in recent weeks
with more than four out of five new
cases comprising of
the new variant as i said mark drexford
is with us
how concerned are you with these numbers
mr drakeford good morning
good morning well they are concerning
numbers we now believe the
new delta variant is in every part
of wales and numbers are rising
in the community not just in specific
settings all of that means that we need
to pause
to collect more data on the extent to
which the new variant will lead to
hospitalizations
in wales and to give us the opportunity
to
vaccinate over half a million
more people in wales particularly with
second doses
and that will rise the level of defense
we have
against this latest coronavirus threat
although i think i'm right in saying in
my first minister that
you're not making it compulsory for care
staff to get the vaccine unlike
in england it would appear why is that
because we already
have very high levels of take-up of the
vaccination amongst care home staff
and we've done that by persuasion and by
conversation
and voluntarily so well over 90 percent
of our care home staff have had a first
dose and nearly 90 percent have had the
second dose
so we're pressing ahead to try and make
sure we have those remaining
uh staff members offer the vaccine
taking up the vaccine
but if you can do it voluntarily then i
think that is a much stronger basis
from which to go on persuading people to
do the right thing
but if they choose not to have a vaccine
they don't have to even though they're
working
with the vulnerable and elderly well i
certainly think that they ought to
uh that's definitely our position here
but there is
a very big step uh taken when you move
into
compulsion uh our belief is that
actually it would undermine
our program in wales which has been the
most successful in the united kingdom
and has been done on the basis of people
knowing
that when they come forward for
vaccination they are helping themselves
of course but they're helping everybody
else as well
and that sense of voluntary
participation
in the program is very important to us
and has been part of our success
may i ask you about your plans on music
venues um
you want them to operate i believe on
the same basis
as hospitality venues what does that
actually look like in practice
uh well it means that you can only do
these things in carefully
regulated and controlled settings where
there's always somebody in charge
to make some make sure the people are
being kept safe
but where it will be possible for music
to be played and comedy gigs to be
carried out
where people are socially distanced
carefully uh
supervised uh and able to do it
in a way that keeps performers and the
audience
safe but nevertheless an important step
ahead in wales
for those small venues that rely on
being able to have
live events of that sort we heard from
the policing minister i'm not sure
whether you heard kit multis at the
start of the program this morning
uh talking about the rape review which
also covers
wales what particular concerns do you
have for the people of wales
well we share the same concerns that you
will have heard from
others that when prosecution rates are
as low as they have been that it
undermines confidence in the system
and particularly it undermines the
confidence of victims
to come forward tell their story and go
through what is
inevitably a very distressing experience
for them
if they think that that distressing
experience doesn't have an outcome
but his that is commensurate with what
they have gone through
then the whole system is undermined so
we certainly hope
that the measures that the uk government
are announcing will be effective
uh in reversing the trends of recent
times
um if i can end on a fun note uh first
minister
please i'm not sure are you a football
fan uh certainly yes
excellent now you're playing italy
aren't you on sunday italy you're on
fire at the moment
um how confident are you well a very big
game
uh for us of course against one of the
big teams uh across europe
but it'll be a very good experience for
the welsh team as we hope they progress
into the knockout stages of the
competition because those will be the
sort of games you face
all the time as we did back in 2016 of
course
so successfully and you're happy that
two and a half thousand uefa
fifa representatives vips as we're going
to call them for short
are going to be allowed into the united
kingdom without any need for
quarantining
well uh you know anything we do of that
sort does add to the risk but i know
that the authorities will have been
planning carefully together
to make sure that those risks are
minimized
and this is a huge tournament isn't it
not just here in wales where it
certainly is huge
but across the whole of europe and
making sure that it can be done in a way
that allows the whole of europe to take
the interest they will be in it i'm sure
that that is being very carefully
thought through and planned
okay i'm going to put you on the spot
before i let you go um full-time
results for tonight's game england
scotland what do you think
oh way way above my uh pay
grade and uh i'll give you a proper
politician's answer
and hope that it'll be a draw okay and
i'm going to push you as a tel as a
presenter who uh interviews politicians
all the time and i need an answer more
than a draw
okay in that case i think it's time for
scotland to show what they can do in
this competition oh
okay controversial it's good to talk to
you thank you mr rexford thank you
yeah gary southgate not going to wales
on his holidays anymore
quick look at the weather for you now
here's nurse
morning it's looking pretty wet for that
game as well i'm afraid
there are heavy and thundery downpours
likely throughout today across many
central southern and eastern parts of
england
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways